bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 4 janvier
merci de nous retrouver pour cette toute
première édition de l'année du 7-8 le
journal je m'associe donc à toute la
rédaction pour vous souhaiter une très
belle année 2016 on commence tout de
suite avec les titres de cette édition
elles ne sont plus 7 mai 12 depuis le
1er janvier cinq communes ont rejoint
saint quentin en yvelines
les compétences de ce nouvel ensemble
officialisée le 9 janvier prochain lors
du conseil d'installation avec quelques
jours de la date anniversaire des
attentats de charlie hebdo et après les
attentats de paris les forces de l'ordre
sont toujours mobilisés julien le cam
secrétaire régional adjoint police
alliance police nationale est l'invité
du journal nous verrons aussi comment
les fêtes de fin d'année se sont
déroulés et la principale information en
ce début d'année c'est la nouvelle carte
des intercommunalités dans les yvelines
il ya désormais dix regroupements
intercommunaux contre 21 auparavant
parmi les changements importants on
notera que vélizy intègre versailles
grand parc mais surtout que saint
quentin en yvelines compte cinq
nouvelles villes les clayes-sous-bois
plaisir villepreux maurepas et
coignières cinq villes dirigées par des
maires de droite la droite fortement
majoritaire dorénavant mais chez logis
devrait ont conservé la présidence
l'installation de ce nouveau conseil se
fera le 9 janvier sien et nous avons
voulu savoir ce que vous pensiez de ce
rapprochement de cet élargissement
vous aviez avec ce micro-trottoir
écoutez c'est une idée moyenne je dirais
c'est mieux que ce qui était prévu à
huit cent mille habitants je pense qu'on
n'a pas intérêt à faire de trop gros
ensemble et que aller jusqu'au plateau
de saclay avec huit cent mille habitants
c'était un petit peu fou mais c'était
une idée du préfet nos élus ont eu
raison de ramener à quelque chose de
plus raisonnable
non mais c'est bien c'est je pense que
ça peut être une bonne idée d'agrandir
si ça permet des structures des tas de
choses qui sont nécessaires est-ce que
ça va nous ramener
moins d'impôts ça m'étonnerait je pense
pas pas pour moi ça va rien changer et
ben l'union fait la force
voilà et l'oignon fait la soupe c'est
bien connu non mais je trouve si tu peux
en et plus on est fort plus on est grand
moins il y aura de gâchis et puis plus
d'efforts seront regroupées jeu direct
et sachez que dorénavant
saint-quentin-en-yvelines compte 240
mille habitants et l'année a bien
commencé pour arlette et olivier qui ont
connu un réveillon pour le moins
mouvementée leur petite fille leni est
arrivé comme un cadeau du nouvel an dans
la nuit du 1er janvier à l'hôpital du
chesnay
elle fera la joie de son grand frère qui
lui est né un 1er avril
un reportage signé fanny bourdon elle
était attendue dans 15 jours mais elle a
fait une belle surprise à sa maman
arlette qui a perdu les eaux à 20 heures
le soir du réveillon
elle était censée arriver le 19 janvier
elle est arrivée avec trois semaines
d'avancé pour notre grande joie
encore ému arlette n'est pas près
d'oublier cette nuit de la saint
sylvestre
à ce titre la petite leni est le premier
bébé né en 2016 à l'hôpital andré-mignot
au chesnay
elle s'appelle l'énigme ben comme vous
savez elle est née le 1er janvier à 2h44
donc c'est le premier bébé de l'année
lenny fait la joie de ses parents et de
son grand frère
on leur souhaite une très bonne année
2016 et en cette période de fin d'année
mais forces de police sont sur le
qui-vive l'état d'urgence est maintenu
pour nous en parler nous recevons julien
le camion soit vous êtes le secrétaire
régional adjoint du syndicat alliance
police nationale
alors pour les fêtes de fin d'année les
mesures de sécurité ont été renforcées
l'état d'alerté au maximum
comment cela s'est déroulé si on les
yvelines bah écoutez comme vous le dites
il y avait une grande présence policière
sur l'ensemble du département il y avait
plus d'une centaine de policiers de la
sécurité publique mobilisée ce qui
représentait à peu près trente cinq
patrouilles sur l'ensemble du
département et on a pu constater que
grâce à l'abnégation et au
professionnalisme des collègues il ya eu
aucun événement
grave à signaler est-ce que les
effectifs étaient renforcés justement
pour ces états de vacances scolaires ce
qu'on craignait qu'il y ait des
attentats voilà tamment à noël aussi
pour le jour de l'an on sait que sur le
60 18 on avait la présence de quelques
sections de crs mais rien de plus par
rapport aux années précédentes il n'y
avait pas de d'effectifs supplémentaires
déployés
c'étaient les grands magasins et mais
également les lieux de culte qui était
voilà justement ce truc sous protection
oui exactement il y avait des lieux de
culte il y avait moins il ya toujours
une également une personnalité qui est
saoul là on va dire sous la
responsabilité la sécurité de la
sécurité publique a choisi une
personnalité qui demeurent sur la celle
saint cloud qui prend aide
seule une patrouille qui mobilise à elle
seule une patrouille de police ont donc
pas d'un incident voilà le dit justement
n'ont aucun incident majeur à signaler
voilà quand même eu des véhicules brûlés
mais aucun incident majeur à signaler
justement voilà vous parlez de de
vandalisme sur les départs témoigner -
voilà deux voitures alizés de voitures
brûlées parce que c'est un événement qui
est souvent un frein c'est souvent le
cas justement euros 31 ou aussi à noël
wii u moins de véhicules par rapport au
précédent réveillon - véhicules brûlés
alors ça je vous le dis on doit on doit
certainement enfin on le doit grain au
professionnalisme voilà au passage des
patrouilles à la présence de mes
collections sur le terrain justement va
ce sera forcément un policier a pu
éviter des actes comme celui ci savent
exactement il ya eu 200 à près de 100
voitures sûres et département quand même
ah non il ya eu une vingtaine de
véhicules
une vingtaine de véhicules de france à
la voile à une vingtaine de véhicules de
brûler sur le département
le 31 décembre votre syndic a diffusé un
communiqué pour dénoncer le laxisme dont
les yvelines que dénonciez vous de quoi
est il question
alors effectivement mes collègues de la
bac versailles ont eu affaire en
l'espace de deux mois à des situations
violentes notamment le lendemain des
événements du 13 novembre donc le 14
novembre via un collègue delà de la bac
de versailles qui a été frappé au visage
un est blessé l'individu interpellé a
été une un rappel à la loi un simple
rappel à la loi
nous dénonçons c'est en outre onze ans
cette décision scandaleuse
c'est un signal c'est un signal
scandaleux qui est qui est donné à mes
collègues comment les magistrats enfin
on vous en expliquer cette situation
justifiait peut-être moi je ne sais pas
mais effectivement nous on fait le
constat que les sanctions ne sont pas
assez sévères
un alliance police nationale nous
dénonçons en fait nous nous souhaitons
qu'il y ait des peines planchers
appliquée aux agresseurs de policiers et
que c'est poli ces délinquants soient
condamnés fermement et non pas un simple
rappel à la loi
si vous laissez vous demander justement
voilà d'arrêter ce laxisme que ce sont
justement vos fort soit renforcée après
les attentats du 13 novembre
parce que il ya aussi beaucoup de
d'interpellations qui doivent être
qu'ils doivent être liées justement à ça
et là vous êtes donc plus de moyens a
effectivement l'année qui vient de se
passer et tu est une année très
éprouvante pour les forces de police
nous n'avons en un an sûrs quasiment
aucun renfort supplémentaire sur le
département en terme d'effectif
aucun moyen supplémentaire il ya une
superposition des missions comme vous
l'avez dit le plan vigipirate renforcé
la coop 21 l'état d'urgence il ya
beaucoup d'heures supplémentaires qui
sont accumulées par les fonctionnaires
et beaucoup de fatigue
alors justement comment fait-on en tant
que policier pour assurer la sécurité
pour être efficace dans ce laps de temps
comme qui est assez long depuis le 13
novembre
bah écoutez en tout cas quand je
rencontre des collègues effectivement
c'est parfois difficile je n'ai pas
vraiment de réponse à leurs données
quand certains passent les deux fêtes de
fin enfin les deux fêtes de fin d'année
au travail et ne voient pas leurs
familles c'est vrai que des fois c'est
compliqué et des vacances des congés et
accorda effectivement nous avons à faire
briller une baisse une baisse due
du taux d'absence significative et du
coup il ya beaucoup de fatigue part dans
les forces de l'ordre il ya une
organisation qui a changé parce que si
l'effectif n'est pas renforcée
comment faites vous pour assurer le
roulement si vous devez assurer la
sécurité dans différents lieux en même
temps là si vous voulez les collègues
font ce qu'ils peuvent avec les moyens
qu'ils ont les moyens les effectifs
je suis sait pas trop comment vous
expliquez soul et nous ça fait un an
qu'ils aient vu les attentats de charlie
hebdo nous attendons des renforts sur le
département mais les seuls renforts
qu'on a vu en fin d'année ça à peine
compensé les départs qui a eu l'été
dernier donc si vous voulez à part le
courage et l'abnégation de mes collègues
on peut pas au niveau des moyens
matériels vous avez reçu rien rien rien
du tout c'est justement ce qu'on ce
qu'on déplore un on n'a même pas de date
concernant les livraisons de moyens
supplémentaires
donc les prix - intervenants sont
toujours sans moyens balistique on a on
n'a pas de quoi faire face à une attaque
terroriste
concrètement justement vous parlez des
attentats de charlie hebdo donc le
triste anniversaire de super content à
algues donc cette semaine ce qu'il va y
avoir plus de précautions qui vont être
prises est ce que justement aussi il
faut peut-être peu à part des citoyens
faire plus attention
non rien rien ne change on est en état
d'urgence jusqu'à fin février
si vous voulez les effectifs policiers
de voie publique sont alors maximum si
vous voulez en termes de présence sur le
terrain on peut pas faire mieux c'est à
dire que les collègues quand je les
rencontre les effets sont les
patrouilles sont au complet
on manque de véhicules même parfois si
l'état d'urgence est prolongée après le
20 février sur les choses vont peut-être
changer pour vous vous l'espérez du
moins on l'espère on l'espère on attend
on attend des effectifs supplémentaires
nous savons qu'en janvier il ya à peu
près 1000 milles personnes qui sont
rentrées dans les écoles de police pour
nous renforcer sauf que la scolarité
dure un an donc si vous voulez les
effectifs les renforts vont arriver
quand justement voilà cette campagne a
été menée pour recruter a eu quand même
un certain effet il ya beaucoup de gens
qui soit au niveau de l'harmonie vaut la
prestine se sont engagés mais ça n'a pas
vraiment d'effet pour vous quel
peut-être situation qui est laide vous
attendez là pour que la situation
s'arrange qu'elle est demain en fin de
compte c'est vrai que mon a tancé ces
renforce et on pourrait imaginer parents
que des policiers de provence viennent
vous prêter main forte en ile de france
non c'est l'organisation est assez
complexe
puis les collègues de province ont
également aussi beaucoup sollicités je
sais que les militaires viennent
beaucoup nous renforcer on a également
des réservistes qui viennent aider dans
certains commissariats mais c'est pas
assez on demande effectivement plus
effectif mais il faut du temps pour les
former est ce que justement voilà donc
l'année 2016 commence fin sous des
auspices plus on part quand même de
sécurité il faut faire attention il ya
des événements qui vont changer ce que
peut-être voilà comme 21 il y avait
beaucoup de sécurité les gros et non
comme ça doit être plus organisés plus
sécurisé vous avez des consignes en ce
sens alors nous sur ce sont 18 pour
l'instant en fait on envoie des
effectifs ponctuellement renfort c'est à
dire que pour la coop 21 il ya des
effectifs due soit 118 qui sont partis
en renfort comme va y avoir certainement
besoin de beaucoup de renforts pour
l'euro 2016
bon bah les effectifs qui partent en
renfort ne sont pas sur le département
donc effectivement est dans une
situation d'état d'urgence fait qu'on ne
souhaite pas évidemment mais qui se
passerait dans le département il est
vrai la possibilité voilà pour la police
d'intervenir rapidement
oui oui sauf que les collègues sont très
courageux et effectivement sont très
professionnels sauf que ont ils n'ont
pas les moyens
la laddh rc peine direction a envoyé
trois fiches pour expliquer comment
réagir face à une attaque terroriste
voilà les collègues le savent déjà cédé
principes d'intervention qu'on a comme
de protéger le citoyen c'est notre
métier
nous ce qu'on manque ces deux moyens et
il faudrait revoir également le cadre de
la légitime défense puisque dans les
mesures qui ont été mises en place à ce
propos donc soit les policiers
municipaux qu'ils soient armés ou que un
policier puisse garder son arme même
quand ils ne travaillent pas non plus
civil vous voulez juger comment vous
pensez que ça elles peuvent être encore
améliorés
fait encore plus de choses qui soient
faites dans ce sens exactement alliance
police nationale nous on se bat pour que
le fonctionnaire de police et le droit
de porter son arme
peu importe sa position administrative
qu'il soit en congé
sur le trajet du travail et ça nous a
été autorisée la actuellement
exceptionnellement que durant l'état
d'urgence voilà donc fin février le
retour là où la réglementation est le
policier devra remettre son son arme
dans l'armoire forte durant les
week-ends durant ses repos merci
beaucoup vu dans le calme d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et à présent
tout autre sujet mangues ananas on
praline la bûche de noël était bien la
star des fêtes de fin d'année pendant
les vacances ce service jeunesse de
trappes a même lancé pour la première
fois un concours de bûches de noël
destinés aux enfants ils étaient une
vingtaine âgés de 6 à 14 ans à
confectionner leur propre recette
au total quatre buts ont été réalisés un
jury devait les départager en fonction
d'une dizaine de critères le goût bien
évidemment mais aussi la couleur et
l'originalité une compétition mais avant
tout un moment convivial on écoute le
coordinateur de l'opération bruno
guilbert qui se sont donné accord de
joie pour seulement réalisé aussi bien
donc leur bouche avec la déco qui va
avec et
vraiment il était on va dire motivés
pour
on va dire travailler à cette
réalisation
vous avez vu aujourd'hui ils vont
pouvoir vraiment déguster donc la bûche
à la fin donc c'est un moment convivial
avant tout avant même le concours ce
moment convivial pour eux les élèves ont
repris le chemin de l'école vous le
savez les vacances sont finies mais
certains ont décidé de mettre leurs
vacances à profit à guyancourt pendant
deux semaines la ville a organisé un
stage de journalisme dédiés aux jeunes
avec l'aide d'une journaliste
professionnel cinq jeunes passionnés ont
pu s'initier au monde des médias en
s'essayant à la rédaction d'un journal
un moyen également de mieux appréhender
l'information un sujet signé sephora
namani et camille lambert des devoirs de
vacances assez particulier pour ces
jeunes si corentin est là aujourd'hui
c'est pour participer à l'élaboration
d'un journal grâce à ce stage organisé
par la ville
5 juillan courtois ont pu découvrir de
l'intérieur le monde du journalisme je
sias caa stage parce que j'ai envie de
devenir toujours à nice plus tard et
puis je pense que c'est une bonne
expérience déjà créé un magazine qu'on a
pu faire
puis de regarder comment on fait les
articles comme entendu les gens qui
étaient supposés apprendre à
hiérarchiser l'information manier les
sources et des différents types de
médias
les adolescents se sont pris au jeu en
s'essayant même à la radio sur marmite
fm
mais aujourd'hui place au bouclage du
journal le premier constat c'était aussi
la liberté d'expression parce que c'est
c'est aussi le fait de pouvoir
s'exprimer déjà et donc donner les
moyens à des jeunes dans la ville de
concours de pouvoir s'exprimer via le
journal vient aussi la radio il ya
l'idée de travailler sur la solidarité
avant tout est donc dans la solidarité
et à la citoyenneté
mais dans la citoyenneté ya l'expression
il ya donc voilà les jeunes sont saisis
de tout ça et ça donne quelque chose
extrêmement intéressants grâce à l'aide
de sandra journalistes professionnels
ces jeunes ont décliné le thème de la
solidarité sous plusieurs angles en
évitant les pièges
c'était vraiment important pour moi de
bien leur expliquer que oui il faut
croire ce qu'on voit mais faut vérifier
il faut savoir ce qui est vrai ce qui
est pas vrai cochez un peu partout pas
s'arrêter au premier article combi et
c'est le premier jour c'était vraiment
leur expliquer le métier du journalisme
et après c'était donc voilà deux créer
ce magazine où il était vraiment un
acteur de a à z c'est qu'ont choisi les
couleurs c'est au cros choisi les artix
un magazine d'une quinzaine de pages que
les guyancourt toi pourront découvrir
d'ici une dizaine de jours
tirage papier ou internet reste encore à
définir le mode de diffusion et vous le
savez chaque commune organise c'était
appétant d'activités périscolaires et
leur contenu alors certains sont plus
originaux que d'autres à l'image de ceux
proposés par la ville de coignières à
l'école marcel pagnol
nous en parlons avec sephora namani dans
la première chronique culturelle de
l'année
on sort sephora mais bonne année merci
vous également
alors oui exactement vous le disiez en
fait les 24 élèves de cm1 de l'école de
coignières de marcel pagnol ont la
chance en fait de découvrir le
fonctionnement de l'appareil
photographique réflexe tous les réglages
qu'il faut mettre en pratique pour
réaliser des nets et des flous justement
jouant avec la profondeur de champ et on
regarde tout de suite les détails avec
camille paillardes enseignante à l'école
marcel pagnol de coignières on a monté
un projet p a qu'un projets éducatifs
artistiques et culturelles sur la
photographie parce que c'est un domaine
qui est un inconnu des enfants qui
apprend aux enfants bas à se servir d'un
appareil photo reflex a du coup
découvrir leur milieu proche d'une autre
façon a observé d'une autre façon et du
coup nous en classe on travaille en
histoire des arts sur les grands
photographes sur les grands courants sur
la technique pour qu'ils aient du coup
quelque chose un petit peu complet alors
c'est fort à cet atelier permet de
développer quelle qualité chez l'enfant
alors hormis bien sûr en fait de savoir
maîtriser les différents
réglages comme l'iso l'ouverture et la
vitesse ça permet également aux enfants
de développer leur sens de l'observation
tout en apprenant à regarder
différemment leur environnement et puis
ça leur apprend également à participer à
un projet collectif
alors comment se déroule comment se
décompose ces ateliers de façon très
pratique alors donc le groupe les 24
élèves sont divisés en deux groupes l'un
est sur le terrain pour apprendre une
forme de mise en pratique de ce qu'ils
apprennent en classe qui est plus
théorique et c'est leur professeur de
classe qui leur enseignent les cours
d'histoire de l'art
donc là on a la vraie lumière rembrandt
on peut comparer entre la photo et la
peinture d'accord maintenant on va
observer la lumière rembrandt sur des
photographies
là c'est une photo est ce qu'on a ici le
triangle rembrandt est ce que tu vois le
triangle de lumière ici on le voit bien
là il est matérialisé justement est-ce
qu'on a les faits clairs obscurs
reda oui on a une partie du visage qui
est éclairée et l'autre qui est sont
donc là est ce que le photographe a
réussi à créer la lumière rembrandt
oui et vous l'avez compris donc pendant
ce temps là l'autre partie de la classe
était sur le terrain avec un photographe
professionnel alors super par contre les
mutants droite
par contre la dengue copains
il n'y a pas des choses sur moi ce que
je te conseille c'est carrément de foot
est simple en comparaison tu fais un
plan plus serré comme ça d'accord ou
alors tout le monde entier à chaque
cours on a vu une une notion différente
d'accord et en fait on l'a travaillé
pendant le cours dont le premier cours
on a parlé des iso avec plus ou moins de
lumière à l'extérieur ou à l'intérieur
d'une régulation publique de l'appareil
ça ils ont bien intégré le court dernier
par exemple on a travaillé la vitesse
là on a travaillé un petit peu tout le
monde connaît flash à la télé donc je
leur montrerai comment on pouvait faire
flasher en faisant disparaître le co
peine de la photo comment régler dans
beaucoup ça nous a permis de travailler
différentes notions techniques par
l'amusement
alors cette fois on voit le photographe
par les 10 aux deux vitesses en ses
mains on a 9 10 ans était un peu trop
jeune pour aborder des concepts qui se
prête à cette technique
alors c'est vrai que j'étais moi même la
première surprise c'est assez surprenant
on sent vraiment que les enfants
comprennent ce qu'ils font et surtout
qu'ils aiment ça et après comment rec 2
les appareils photo j'ai appris comment
étaient des photos comment comment on
allume et les appareils photo et du
comminges amiens un photographe est les
réglages les modes manuels et les
réglages de ciseaux et les réglages
telle ouverture ou du focal et on a
après l'ouverture c'est du studio qu'est
ce que tu aimes tu as évoqué des photos
faire des photos m'amuser avec mes amis
travailler avec mes amis et la
motivation supplémentaire également pour
eux c'est qu'il parte de semaine en
classe de neige en janvier avec leurs
intervenants en photographe photographie
pardon et tous les matins ils seront
invités à expérimenter différentes
prises de vues des portraits des
paysages à la neige et à organiser une
restitution fin février courant mars
avec les plus beaux clichés des enfants
effectivement c'est une belle motivation
de partir au ski sont faire des photos
merci ces forums on vous retrouve
mercredi pour un nouveau numéro de
kiosques premiers de l'année exactement
où se préparent les belles surprises
j'espère alors oui on va parler cinéma
on va pas
maj illusionnisme et musique très bien
maintenant nous allons parler sport
ils l'ont fait le club demande dernière
équipe il une fois encore en course pour
la coupe de france a réussi l'exploit de
se qualifier pour les 16e de finale de
la compétition en battant le stade
briochin le score 2 buts à 0 retour sur
cette qualification le reportage est
signée michael elle me d'euros et fanny
bourdon une victoire historique le fc
mantois 78 club de cfa a réussi
l'exploit de se hisser en seizièmes de
finale de la coupe de france en battant
difficilement sur son terrain le stade
briochin une équipe de cfa2 le score 2
buts à 0 avec des réalisations de
francis massampu et brûlent auprès rats
dans les arrêts de jeu une qualification
au forceps sur le match on peut pas se
vanter d'avoir été au dessus au dessus
on a eu la chance d'ouvrir le score au
bon moment de la partie à prendre a subi
mais bon comme ce qui compte c'est de
passer des regrets d'avoir encaissé ce
but là parce que finalement ils nous
marquent le but sur leur seule
demi-occasion c'est même pas une
véritable occasion donc le regret il est
là je fais si tu as sûrement toi c'est
eux qui ont gagné ils sont passés même
si on peut considérer qu'on a été
meilleurs que sur ce match là mais au
final c'est moi qui seront 16e donc les
citations
avec cette victoire le fc mentaux a
écrit l'une des plus belles pages de son
histoire depuis sa création en 1994 le
club n'avait jamais dépassé le stade des
32e de finale de la coupe de france
c'est sûr parce que les gens vont
retenir c'est la qualification
même dans 10 ans on pourra dire qu'on a
fait 1 16e
pour ceux qui l'ont vécue c'est vrai que
c'était difficile en 16e de finale le
dernier représentant évinois de cette
coupe de france pourrait recevoir à la
maison des clubs de ligue 1 comme le
paris saint germain monaco lyon ou
encore marseille
ce qu'on souhaitait déjà c'était attend
des seizièmes de finale
maintenant qu'on est en combi et
pourquoi pas une ligue 1 et pourquoi pas
un voisin entendant le psg mais ça c'est
le souhait de n'importe quel club en
france
réponse ce lundi 4 janvier à 19h30 pour
le tirage les supporteurs ne demande
qu'à rêver
le début des années 2000 16 aura bien
réussi car le match a eu lieu le samedi
1er janvier 2016 et justement en ce
début d'année il est de tradition de
prendre de bonnes résolutions alors se
mettre au sport voyages et arrêter de
fumer ou rester zen quelles sont celles
qui reviennent le plus souvent quelles
sont vos bonnes résolutions de l'année
2016 c'est ce que nous vous avons
demandé regarder quand on se rappelle
tout les événements de l'année 2015
notamment ceux du 13 novembre sans
oublier de janvier 2015 si avec charlie
je crois que c'est des choses qu'on
n'oubliera jamais est ce qu'il faut
souhaiter c'est conviés dans un monde de
paix une meilleure année que l'année
dernière obligatoirement tout le monde
le souhaite je pense et puis puis de
façon ça peut être que mieux
vous avez retrouvé ses plus importants
la santé et que ça se passe un peu mieux
que 2015 surtout du bonheur de la santé
et puis la paix sur deux mais vivre en
paix la paix le calme la sérénité voilà
il me to bonheur et puisque nous
évoquions les voeux mais aussi les
résolutions pour l'année 2016
sachez que certains maires ont décidé de
ne pas organiser les l'heure pas de
cérémonie de voeux à saint cyr par
exemple le maire l'est républicain
évoque des mesures supplémentaires trop
coûteuses afin d'assurer la sécurité en
cette période d'état d'urgence
le préfet en effet demandé de limiter
les manifestations publiques
la ville entend ainsi réaliser des
économies alors que les dotations de
l'état sont en diminution pour 2016 les
villes de poissy de fontenay le fleury
ou encore la ville socialiste de trappes
ont pris une décision similaire
et c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis tout de
suite vous avez rendez vous avec michael
elle me d'euros pour la reprise du site
hui sport la première de l'année à ne
pas rater quant à moi je vous retrouve
demain pour un nouveau numéro du journal
je vous souhaite donc une très bonne
année mais aussi une très belle soirée